hello today I'm talking to Daria and
Misha of deployed deployed is part of
stability Ai and has previously released
a model called if which is what we're
talking about today if is an open source
replication of Imagine which is a model
out of Google research and has been
presented in this paper right here
photorealistic text to image diffusion
models with deep language understanding
so this model the if model is different
in that it does not go to a latent space
like stable diffusion but it operates
directly on Pixel space so the diffusion
process is happening on Pixel space and
then it works with up Samplers at the
end we're talking today a little bit
about how everything came to be how
everything fits together but the model
is really cool and if you go look up
examples out of this the Productions of
the model are very very performant of
course now we have bigger models coming
out every every day but given the time
it was developed and you know the size
of the model and everything it does some
things particularly well for example
text so you can see here all the text
that's here is much better capture than
for example stable diffusion 1.5 or
something like this so I think that this
model has been forgotten a little bit
next to all the dalis and stable
diffusions and so on being released and
I hope people will check out this line
of research more so enjoy this
conversation with Darian Misha and I'll
see you around bye bye
hello everyone today I have with me two
people whose last names I will not be
able to pronounce but for now I will
call them Dasha and Misha of the deep
Floyd
teamisha Welcome very much to here very
cool what you're doing hello Yannick
hello thanks a lot for having us so
listeners we have about like half a
second or a second lag here and we'll
try to correct it in the edit but at
some sometimes you you'll hear like some
awkward pauses that is the internet's
fault and not because we are anti-social
people deep Floyd
um there are a few names up here uh
We've what we've seen come out from you
is a really great text to image model
it's a model that similar to stable
diffusion and Dolly I can put in a piece
of text and then an image will pop up
but it has some notable differences and
I feel it gives it gives a really great
pictures that do actually follow what I
write it's for example very good at also
text as we can see maybe on the screen
there is a neon sign this is fully
created just from text so there's no
reference image or anything like this
and we we see a few names right here so
maybe you can just tell us what is the
model itself called and what is it at
its core like what's what's the model
architecture so yeah the model name
deployed Eve so we are deployed team we
are part of stability I uh as a research
group we are more interesting in
multimodal neural networks such as
deployed eform maybe you will hear some
new networks soon from us so deployative
is a diffusion model is a pixel cascaded
diffusion model and then you want to
like describe how
stable diffusion works it's very easy to
just Google uh stable like deployative
and uh you will see that its model
composed on Frozen text encoder and free
cascaded pixel diffusion models uh blah
blah blah but what does it mean we have
architecture that is very similar to
imagine
and uh it use frozen T5 encoder as uh
first like zero stage to Pro to process
text into embeddings and after that we
have free cascaded uh units that convert
the image from text to 64 by 64 then to
uh
256 by 256 and to 100
1024 by 1024.
so this is like the core idea of the
architecture but
um I hope we will can we can discuss
more details about how we decide uh to
use some specific text encoders and what
the difference between our model and
imagine for example I can just add yes I
can just add that
um the name of our model if is inspired
by the song If by uh Pink Floyd very
cool I was wondering yes I think
yeah yeah so you pronounce it just if
that's cool yeah I was wondering if it's
like image Floyd or something like this
since you're called Deep Floyd or um but
that clears it up thank you yes I just
wanted to say that there was a hint in
our first uh post in Twitter
actually
because we changed a bit uh like some
words from this song very very very nice
I did not know this but I'll go back and
see I think the most notable difference
here is specifically whereas for example
stable diffusion Works in this latent
space that is given by a VQ gun uh with
with latent tokens
the your model specifically works on
pixels themselves so it's a diffusion
model over pixels in a space of 64 by 64
pixels
why did you choose this
um when for example stable diffusion in
many models before or have found that it
works very well to do this in this
latent space
so it's very very good question because
like we think that the Latin space is
maybe the best space we have now because
it can generate very good and realistic
images now and don't have this problem
what we have like using several Cascades
if the some artifacts occur on the low
stage you just increase and
um and use it in the second stage and
after that you have some a little bit
muddy non-perfect non-ideal uh
image and in this same time Latin space
have Advantage uh that you just need to
create your base model in the latent
representation shoe you so you don't
worry about the second stage and third
stages in terms of compute and to train
in other parts of model and to try to
like somehow
play this distribution to reduce the
artifacts but in the same time we found
that nowadays we had a lot of research
papers that are based on Imogen for
example dream Fusion these 3D nerve idea
so it was initially made in pixel space
of course you can do it in London and
but there are some some ideas that have
been made for Pixel models and we don't
have them so it is the first problem we
have and the second one for example is
the uh
image you see on your screen for example
if you want to do the Imaging painting
and you want to have the
initial image and don't want to change
it you won't have like pixel perfect
match between your original image and
impacted one so you should use pixel
cascaded because no latent modem can
guarantee you the ideal correctness of
the output
the fact that you work in 64 by 64
pixels and then you use up sampling
models to do that is that mainly a
technical limitation by the fact that
you know that was the biggest you could
train or did you actually find
that somehow this size of image is
advantageous because it right naively
one would just say hey why don't we just
work in 1024 pixel space if we do pixel
diffusion anyway so why do you do the
the 64 by 64. I guess
um
it was the source of our inspiration and
we just wanted like step by step to
reproduce it
but so and imagine uh on the base model
on the first stage they used 64 by 64
resolution and then upscale it to
256 by 256 and further to 124
1024 by 1024. so we just decided uh to
do
um
the same thing but uh later we made some
alterations from the initial image and
architecture I think we'll tell about
them later on
so yeah the main reason is based on
Imogen so that we think is that uh just
not only reproducing the previous idea
they also agreed with them in time in
term of compute and
um efficience of the parameters we use
so for example the second stage we have
this stage that can convert the 64 by 64
image to 256 to 256 can generate the
image from scratch how it works uh the
upsampled image have the argumentation
so this argumentation level have the
bound from zero to one and one may mean
like it's almost gaussian noise so you
see nothing you the Imogen paper propose
it because we have a lot of artifacts
and mismatching term of distribution of
real images and generated
so this kind of augmentation help to
generate more realistic image for
seconds for second stage but if you use
the highest level of augmentation it
means one so you see no condition at all
and so you can do unconditional just
only text conditional generation using
the second stage but the quality of this
image it's really not enough so maybe if
we have we will have a train very very
very large in terms of parameters and
video around model we can do it but I
think it's like idea to save the compute
to separate in three stages
um
maybe you can go into this a bit more
like what given
the the Imagine model what were the most
significant changes you made
um with with respect to going away from
Imagine
so uh I hope uh maybe maybe we will
start what uh we not 100 percent try to
replicate Imogen so in the time where
you maybe remember edifi from Nvidia
they made some model of it
um
use clip and uh T5 encoders together so
Daria will tell you so we had this
experience before them but
uh
at first we decided to make some
experiments uh
on whether which kind of text encoder to
use so we had to decide
it and we conducted several experiments
with uh different text encoders
uh for instance we tried ul2 model plus
clip uh T5 plus clip uh just clip just
five uh text and quarters and just
ul2
and it turned out that the best result
shows the combination of ul2 plus clip
text encoders
so here
we can see that it has it has the best
average clip score
uh but uh even if in
um
imagine paper for instance uh they say
that uh
the company that T5 and clip text
encoder they are they perform similarly
in terms of uh clip score but uh human
evaluation shares that T5 is better
and
here is the same
uh we
just looked at the images that were
generated
so we conducted human evaluation and it
turned out that T5 is actually uh the
best so even here we see that
um
T5 with T5 the model can generate this
triangle pink stop sign
and so
um
yes it is we see that there are more a
real triangle uh stop signs than in some
than in generations with uh different
with another text encoders
and moreover we decided that uh UL tour
actually is very heavy and uh
I think that it's too much it doesn't
makes that big difference you know to to
use such big text encoder in the model
so we we decided that T5 is an optimal
choice in terms of the number of
parameters and their performance
so yeah I think
um sorry if if you talk about T5 and ul2
and so on do you mean just the model
architecture or do you take the actual
pre-trained model weights of these of
these models
actual pre-trained weights of the model
and like to use it as text coder
a frozen one yeah yes definitely
so yeah the idea why we are not like
replica of Imagine by the like core idea
but uh making the same experience that a
defeat made Nvidia made in the parallel
I think they found that
um in our case we don't want to do some
I don't know additional changes in
architecture to like find something that
makes uh our model new and find some new
way to do better model using additional
color but we really tried it so but
still we made several uh changes but we
think is crucial to achieve the best FID
for our days so first thing they didn't
agree a little bit that unit size is not
crucial we found on our experiments that
uh really this size is like matter in
this case so the smallest model is not
enough so I will not cover here at all
but we think I want to tell you it's the
difference in term of unit so we found
that imagine proposed efficient unit the
idea that maybe it's better to use more
parameters and more we run for
Activation in more deeper layers but not
use them in the Higher One
so we found that maybe we can do the
same thing but we'll rearrange it a
little bit and create the optimal unit
like they call it official we call it
optimal Vibe we think it's optimal so we
found the lack a little bit the lack of
um cross-attention layers in the jeeper
blocks so they think that information
for upscalers have to be conditioned on
the text the text condition is crucial
in this kind of architectures and we
think that maybe we can add reduced
number of blocks but add more cross
attention to the text to have a better
text alignment and we found that the
heaven vanilla unit and optimal unit
with almost the same parameters the 400
and 450 parameters we cannot match them
exactly because it's a slightly
different architecture we found that the
loss uh like MSE laws uh from the
training this diffusion it's much much
much lower using this optimal unit for
second stage so this is not the
efficient unit but it's like own idea to
rearrange the second and third stage for
this model
um so this is like main difference I
think and what have you in all it seems
like you've done a lot of exploration of
the architecture trying out different
things rearranging things more layers
more attention and so on
um and if we look at your output quality
it's it's pretty good what piece would
you say made the biggest impact on like
what is if I were to just go now and
build myself a thing like this without
reading much right I just kind of try
what is the is there like one piece of
advice that you give to someone who just
wants to go out and build something like
what's the most important thing
um to pay attention to
yeah I I think it's like my opinion I
think maybe Dasha has another opinion
because it's like really our own thing I
think the most uh crucial thing for me
is to have the good text encoder as a T5
maybe you'll too maybe some better uh
encoder decoder part to take just good
encoder the Frozen one we try to unfroze
it we try to train it so we didn't uh
succeed with that so they think the
Frozen uh encoder the big frozen coder
and good trained Frozen color is crucial
and also they think that see the base
unit sites it's also means a lot because
it's given more parameters for cross
attention for better interpretation with
text embedding from text encoder for
example if you try some simple promises
you can see for example a photo of Red
Cube even like stable diffusional all
other models that have simple uh text
encoder can generate this simple prompt
because like the is a small amount of
information but you remember the time
that people try a lot of different
things in term of prom tricks for
example uh
uh I don't know trending on our station
Yara Yara and all this stuff helps to
create better image and uh but by the
adding a lot stuff in your prompt but
you maybe you don't want to type a lot
of things you just want a simple
expression you want for example Red Cube
on the top of a blue cube and you want
text blue on a Red Cube and text red on
a blue cube you don't want like a lot of
from troops tricks to do the correct
output but uh for doing that you really
need good first stage the good text
encoder and the more parameters for
cross attention and to interpretate this
text and for example if you compare the
results with stable diffusion and the
stable deployed Eve and also mid-journey
V5 with deployative you will see that
um
it's as Impossible by them to create
correct uh image and if you if the main
idea to understand text correctly I
think the bigger unit and the uh cooler
text and cooler and Frozen text encoders
are crucial yeah but but by the also
think but I think that maybe latent is
not the bad thing because we we see a
lot of artifacts in our pixel cascaded
approach so we think they may be using
Latin to you can combine these two cool
ideas and have the best model
yes and I think what also you should
bear in mind uh deciding which size of
the model to choose is also like the
size of your data set and it's very
important to make some experiments
on like scaling and to see if there is
some overfitting problem for instance
and actually imagine uh in their paper
they write that they didn't struggle
with overfitting but but we actually
we're not sure about that that it's true
because with the the size of uh our
model with we have the biggest model is
uh two point three billion parameters uh
and we definitely have some overfitting
issues and by overfitting what how does
overfitting look like in a model like
this like it would always produce the
same image or it would just fail if the
text is not in the training set or how
does how does overfitting look uh well
uh for instance if there is some very
popular image for instance Mona Lisa
which you can see on different surfaces
so on it can be on the mag it can be on
a t-shirt it can be as it is
so uh it's very hard to make some
alterations with this type of image so
in most cases you just get the just the
initial Mona Lisa image
so it's much easier to make some
alterations and variations of images if
it's some like normal image with no
overfitting but with this type of images
yes it's really just hard to get some
variations of it
yeah I mean it does make sense it
appears in the training set probably
ton right
um yeah I I mean I I think so oh nice so
you can see like Mona Lisa I also love
that
but the only one in head so why it's so
because it's so many time on different
prints Etc so it's just remember it by
heart and cannot hallucinate it on it in
terms of FID score our model
demonstrates uh the best results result
we can see that zero showed FID at 30k
is 6.66
and it it is actually uh the first
uh score we get
once we calculated it but then we just
realized that probably the process of
calculating FID score of evaluating such
model
legs
consistency and transparency
we mean that
there are 40K
images in Cocoa Evolution set right
and the zero short feed is calculated on
a subset of 30k images
and the and we should also take into
consideration that for each image in
Cocoa evaluation set there are five
captions so we have actually many
variants of this
caption text pairs
and there is no a predefined set on
which every text to image model can be
evaluated
and we just decided to look at their
pred of fid
scores which are calculated on different
subsets
of a 30k images
and on this slide we can see that
actually uh
like for instance uh we we took 1K
subsamples generated with different
classifier free guidance values
I mean uh one case of samples of this
um
30k sets
of images
and it turned out that there is a huge
difference
between them so for instance FID at 30k
minimum score is 6.50 eight and the
maximum value is 6.76
and the problem is
if you look here we can we can see that
imagine has a FID score
7.27 and party
7.23 so we can see that the difference
is in the second uh like second number
second sign of like after Comer
so it means that and we don't know on
which uh
caption and image sub sample
of this 40K cocoa evaluation images uh
is calculated fid4 Imaging or for party
so it means that it can be not
statistically significant there's a
difference between imagine FID score and
party FID score because here for
instance the difference is even in the
first number of Tacoma
so and we think that probably
it's better to to have some
predefined set of images on which all
text to image models can be evaluated or
probably
uh it it is better to show some mean
score for instance to have uh one k sub
samples of this 30k sets and Report some
mean score but
so so
um we think that it makes sense just to
make this procedure clear and consistent
maybe adding some I don't know fixed
data set subset of these images because
it's very hard to ask people to
recalculate it for all 4K is
historically made for using this random
subset in 30k so it's very hard to ask
people okay now we decide to use all all
uh evolves set from cocoa but maybe just
fixed for future some subset which
should be fixed and yeah but it's not
even a perfectly clear why do we use 30k
uh
samples I mean we can use like the whole
evaluation set why not but it's
historically yeah
yeah but
change it because it's a bit mess in in
calculating FID score if you read
different research papers
so yeah
so it could very conceivably be that
some of these other models they just got
lucky or unlucky with their choice of
subset and then yeah it could it could
be that
um I'm honestly surprised how still I
mean I get it that there is an ambiguity
and so on but overall I'm still
surprised by how uh reliable the FID
metric as such still seems to be because
the metric is really old right and it
uses if I'm if I'm correct it uses this
Inception V3 or V4 Network to somehow
calculate a distance to reference images
I would have guessed that with the rise
of such good models that produce images
um it would be it would be kind of a
meaningless metric until now
um but it seems to be still the fact
that okay you know as sort of models Get
Better perceivably by humans they also
get largely better in this FID score so
there still still seems to be a bit of a
direction in this which is cool to see
but I totally see your your point of
maybe we should fix the subset maybe you
could do that right maybe you could make
um a little paper that says hey here is
a new Benchmark that's fixed and so on
and then everyone I mean it takes
someone to to say look here is what we
do from now on So You Know so this is
very old metric that show just the
similarity of distribution of generated
images by these captions and cocoa image
so if you use some prompt tricks for
example you add like the old photo from
internet from 2014. it will be even
close to this cocoa data set because
it's very old and made in four thousand
fonteen I mean yeah cool excellent and
you also have some some cool Generations
uh I hear
so maybe we can we can get into that a
little bit because I've already seen
some very cool ones on the on the
website but I'm very sure you have
the best examples
yeah these
maybe a few things I can cover it's what
the
we want to show the the model can
generate not even photorealistic model
but the model of this good text
understanding we thought for realism
it's here it's very yummy very real like
Photo uh we also made the model that can
somehow generate the fingers uh we train
it before mid Journey version five so we
see that my journey made a lot of effort
and work to generate more proper hand
but it's like a good test uh like void
comp test from uh Blade Runner for this
kind of models now we can do hands this
is not not a good test anymore they can
also generate a good text on the images
uh very realistic with some maybe it's
easy to add this kind of stacks on in
Photoshop because it's just
straightforward even this but if you
want to do maybe some print on your
T-shirt or even on your head
so yes you can like add
a texture in your text
uh yes if you would like to eat to be as
if it is embroidered on some clothes
or made of some stained glass you you
can do it with the model
yes and uh we were a bit surprised to
find out that
um
our models shows some multilingual
ability
is it I don't know sorry
ah it's somewhere there somewhere here
uh yes it turned out that the model
um
it's uh definitely because of T5 text
encoder the model can understand some
text in a different languages other than
English but it it is
European some European languages so we
can't our model can't understand some
uh text
from some other linguist linguistical
branch
uh but
um it understands some European
languages such as German or French for
instance here we can see that uh it
perfectly generates uh black cars
whether you would like it to be in
German or in French
also with
so we can see that it clearly
understands colors and some
simple objects such as cars for instance
but it also uh that's uh quite well with
some long descriptions actually so here
uh we have this uh description of an
appliance or compartment which is
artificially kept cool and used to store
food and drink and this is definitely a
fridge and we can see that the model
understands it even if this long
description is in German or in French
and it's very funny that if you put this
description in German
the resulted images are empty fridges
they're also whether empty weather full
of some bottles drinks probably beer
because as we all know German like beer
yeah whether when you use English or
French proms you you see bridges that
are full of some vegetables some meals
and so on
yeah which is especially interesting I
because if I understand correctly you do
train the model on the and a subset of
lion 5B that is mostly just English
captions yeah
even more special that it then starts to
to really understand or that it does
really understand the these uh
cross-lingual things which is quite cool
yeah true uh and here is some fun
example but it actually assures that
like
the tokenization isn't perfect uh here
we can see like a green apple and a
black backpack
and we see that uh in French this word
backpack is sakadu
uh but uh like the bag just some women
bag is stuck
so we see that on this Generations
uh which comes from from French text we
see
only women bags bags and no no backpacks
yeah and one more interesting example so
a national if you put a national dish
you really get some national dish and if
you put this prompt into our model so in
German it's
but in German uh gericht is also a court
but but this word National Grid it
um
relates only to a national dish actually
because as far as I know uh the the word
like National court is the national
nationalist I think and it's two
different words as far as I know but
here we all always get a national Court
a building of a national Court
foreign
that is super it's super interesting I
have to say
um yeah especially especially
considering that the fact that it sort
of learned this aligned embedding from
the T5 space or the the T5 space has
somehow this learned embedding space and
then
um it's essentially an English generator
on top of this embedded space
um
yeah so I I can confirm that um being a
German speaker that nuts and algorith is
usually just a dish and and the court
would like the word national would
probably not even appear in most cases
so yeah but it's still like I was I was
I just needed to laugh when I saw that
because it's kind of so obvious why the
model makes that mistake but it's still
like super interesting that it does so
yeah very cool you you said before that
um you don't need that many prompt
tricks and so on do you have
recommendations for people who want to
use this model what's the best way to
prompt it like what's the best stuff to
put in the positive prompt and can I
what what should I put into the negative
prompt and something like this
uh so what I just want to tell what I
found by generating different stuff my
friend uh make these like image a Dev
will come and she will have your eyes
see he spent about one maybe two hours
to generate it so because these are
there is a lot a lot of text on it it is
very very hard to generate such a huge
amount of text so what he did is to add
this text several times in the prompt
like about free time in different quotes
in one quotes and two quotes so I don't
know is it really helps but adding text
several times really helps
and sometimes
um it helps to quote some concepts for
instance uh you would like to make
something with some several Concepts and
if you quote like
this concept to make it
um
more like separable
sometimes it also can help to get the
result that you want much faster
yeah the models you said they come in
different sizes and so on if I'm just if
let's say I'm a you know some home user
some hobby user I have maybe a large
gaming GPU or so what's what's the
biggest model that I can conceivably run
as a single person and what do I need
for the biggest model to run
so yeah for nowadays uh I think that if
you have like your gaming PC at your
home for example
for 100
4090 arctics and media with 24 gigabyte
GB of vram so what you can do you can
use the largest model we have you have
the Excel stage one so
4.3 billion parameters so you can do
classifier free guidance diffusion uh in
the same time without any like
wiggling with it so you can just
generate the correct image in the first
stage the second stage and use your
Frozen T5 encoder but if you not saw
like lucky to have this kind of gaming
PC so there has a lot of hacks that hug
and face team made so by even using free
collab you can use I I deployed if model
with the largest uh
uh like with the largest way I mean
choosing the biggest
um biggest uh best one like second stage
and the upscaler in now we didn't
release our own first stage but you
using model architecture oh
our stage yeah so we haven't yet
released the second upscaler model
so yes but it's possible to use it with
a stable X4
so we've offloaded and uh some stuff
that were made you can use just free
collab if you don't have your own PC or
just hug and face space to generate some
images
cool
um yeah let's talk about releasing the
model a little bit so this is currently
released on the Hub at least the the
first and second stage right the text
encoder is an existing one
um and this specifically released under
a non-commercial license for now
um there's also the paper is still
coming uh still coming out
um what's your what are your plans for
releasing this I have heard at some
point too you'll you know it's going to
be made available later under a
commercially friendly license what are
the considerations there why is why is
it not just fully commercial right now
or what are the you know what's kind of
the thinking behind the release process
here
yeah it's a very very hard question it's
more about like legal stuff and the
stability so now we had a compute and
ability to train the uh deploy different
model and really happy to share with
communities so the way how we can uh do
it more step by step it's the way where
we can first of all do initial Alpha
Testing this initial Alpha Testing
include 100 percent that try our model
and found some like pros and cons they
found some non-safe issues with our
model and we fix them by changing the
data set by also adding some filters on
the online training phase and also on an
inference phase so we try to make our
model as safe as it can be for releasing
it to like
um commercially from the stability and
now we'll be on a stage where we can
give an access for all the people around
the world to try Iowa model and also for
researchers for example we found that uh
by using deployative model there is some
concepts for what I'm originally made
for uh imagen for example gym Fusion are
already made for deployed if and this is
some repository you can find and try
this model but it's also using our own
license right because to generate this
kind of text to 3D you have this part
deployed different site and you need to
agree with this license and this is now
it's like research only but we hope that
like gradually the stability we can do
it's like more open and even commercial
one and also we have some ideas in the
future to release the next generation of
if maybe on the topic of stability
um well it's not clear to me quite yet
is your relationship to stability AI
sometimes they do sponsor compute
sometimes they are shareholders of
company if I understand that correctly
sometimes it's just a loose Association
how how does the deploy team instability
what how do they work together or what's
their relation there so we are like part
of stability so deploy it to our lab
it's just part of stability so
yeah like
for instance yeah yeah yes
and some other teams
Harman Ai and
yeah is there is there um do you have
how much Freedom do you have to decide
what to research on like can you do what
you like can you have your ideas or is
there like a very top down like oh you
now need to do this text to the fusion
model or how does how does that come to
be because it's a very special situation
it's it's open source but it's also a
company and there are a lot of
researchers involved so I'm very
interested in how that works how do you
get to decide what to work on
so yeah this is like was like our like
initial discussion with the mod
we had an idea to create this open
source large pre-trained models so we
found that it's like our Common Ground
here that stability won't but the same
thing we want so we decide to be part of
stability and do this stuff and by
deciding the core idea and using like
pixel cascaded diffusion in the same
time where the Robin and his team made
the legend diffusion we are doing so
once one more text to image model with
in a parallel very similar one using
almost identical data set and all the
decision we made in team like was like
our internal decisions I think we have a
lot a lot of freedom but the only thing
what we want to do all together is to
releasing this kind of model and do have
this kind of model to find the compute
on them so I have I think we have a huge
freedom in terms to decide what to train
and how to do this architecture and how
to made it but also we shoot to train it
properly and do the best to open source
it
yeah we really appreciate that yeah we
really appreciate that with the
instability we have a really great uh
research freedom to choose uh well which
architecture would like to use which
decisions would like to make I mean
in terms of optimization
and stability really is happy to provide
us compute
and like the the main the main goal of
stability and of like
our team is to release in the end some
open source models excellent
um so last question from me given you
have this model now there is a release
process ongoing I'm gonna guess that's
more on the side of the legal team and
so on what is next for for you what is
next for deep Floyd
um do you want to continue this line of
research do you already have some some
some higher goal in mind or what you
know where are you going so yeah uh now
we
finish the deployative model so we try
to think what we do next we have several
ideas how to do next again text to image
model we also have some ideas about
maybe working in another domain of
multimodal architectures but for now we
are thinking that maybe one of the
streams will be to continue doing these
open source
state-of-the-art text to image models so
we're thinking to doing if two
yeah and it's it's cool that with
instability there are
several teams which are special
specialized on different
domains for instance there is a team
that works with the sound there is a
team that works to images and so on and
so we can collaborate cooperate with
each other and try some multi-modal
architectures cool is there any last
thing you would like the community to
know or you would like to get out there
about your model about your team or just
about the general general direction
you'd like to see in the community
so yeah as a team we will be happy to
see maybe more ideas how to use deployed
if model if it possible to see maybe uh
some pull requests and ideas how to
optimize it and maybe we will try to do
some stuff more than the community maybe
some open train like how it can be done
it's very hard question but maybe we
will try it so definitely come to our
Discord server we don't have like some
bought and free generation there but
there is some group and discussion so we
will be happy to talk all right that's
excellent well Misha and Dasha thank you
very much for being with me today and
this was an absolute pleasure
thank you Yannick for us as well thank
you